Last month, [music] a free model you can
download and run yourself tied Claude's
best coding model head-to-head. They
solved 25 tasks each [music] out of 45
and gave the same answer on 43 of them.
That's the number that started turning
heads.
>> [music]
>> It's also the most misleading number in
this whole comparison because tied one
curated benchmark and replaces [music]
are not the same sentence. The model is
GLM 5.2. Open weights MIT license built
by a Chinese lab called ZAI.
>> [music]
>> A former Meta and DeepMind VP called it
the first open model that passes [music]
the bar as a daily driver. Perplexity
CEO said he was impressed, almost
shocked at how good it is at coding
[music] and that it changes things. So,
did the frontier just fall? Almost. By
the end of this, you'll know exactly
where a free model beats one that costs
five [music] times as much, where it
breaks down, and the one cost number
that flips the entire it's cheaper
argument upside down. For years, open
models trailed the frontier by
comfortable margin. Epoch AI tracks that
gap and their measurement is a
respectable headline. Since the start of
2026, the best open weight models sit
about four months behind the best closed
ones on capability. [music]
GLM 5.2 is the loudest data point in
that collapse. It's the first open model
developers use as a daily driver instead
of a weekend curiosity. On the
independent intelligence index, it's the
number one open model on Earth, a few
points behind Opus and GPT 5.5, [music]
ahead of everything else you can
download. It's a mixture of experts
model, 753
billion parameters total, around 40
billion active at any moment with a
million token context window. And the
big labs paid attention because you can
download it. The weights are yours.
Renting Claude or GPT means the model
lives on someone else's server, priced
how [music] they choose, switched on and
off when they choose. Three weeks ago,
Anthropic's top model got export
suspended overnight. And teams with
pipelines wired to it had to downgrade
the same afternoon. A model sitting on
your own disk can be repriced, retired,
or taken away. The read on local Llama
was blunt. You can't justify a
multi-billion dollar valuation when open
weights match you for the price of
electricity. So, what does GLM 5.2 do
well? Back-end and systems work.
Low-level C concurrency. Rust Vulcan
reviewers keep handing it the
unglamorous plumbing and keep coming
away impressed.
>> [music]
>> Debugging and security audits are its
stand-out lane. In one test, it found a
bug that Opus, GPT, and DeepSeek all
walked straight [music] past. On a class
of access control vulnerability, it beat
Claude outright, 39% to 32. This is the
model that reads the code carefully
instead of pattern matching a
plausible-looking answer. And clean
one-shot builds, dashboards, data vis,
front-ends that render correctly on the
first try. On a same task test where a
reviewer built a full CRM with each
model, the GLM run came to $4.15.
The Opus run cost $21.27, [music]
roughly five times more for work he
rated only a hair better. The pitch for
the people that [music] use these
models, GLM for the volume, the frontier
model for the hard 10%. [music]
Now, the reason it can just drop into
your current setup, GLM 5.2 is
text-only. It has no vision. It cannot
[music] see a screenshot, a design mock,
a rendered UI, or chart you paste in.
For a huge slice of real front-end and
product work, make it match this Figma,
here's the broken layout, fix it, you're
asking it to paint blindfolded. This
rules it out of an entire category of
daily work, and no amount of benchmark
parity closes it.
>> [music]
>> And the moment the task turns visual and
iterative, 3D, 3JS, physics you have to
eyeball and nudge, the head-to-heads go
lopsided. Claude [music] takes a massive
lead as soon as the work needs eyes.
Now, let's look beyond the initial
impressive data. That that heat
benchmark from the intro, vendor run, 45
curated tasks [music] on a tuned
harness. Move to the independent agent
evaluations, the ones measuring long
autonomous multi-file work, [music] and
the picture shifts. Artificial Analysis
Coding Agent Index, GLM scores 58, Opus
73,
GPT-5.5
running in Codex, 76.
On a contamination-free software
engineering test, GLM lands at 29% while
Opus hits 56, and GPT clears 64. [music]
On the longest horizon marathon test,
the multi-hour autonomous jobs, GLM
scores 13. Opus scores 26. That's
double.
The pattern holds across every rigorous
test. GLM ties or nearly ties on short
bounded tasks, and slips hard on the
longest least supervised ones. Close,
but a clear step behind on the tail
relevant for autonomous coding. There's
also a failure mode worth naming because
both sides do it, and GLM does it more.
>> [music]
>> Declaring "Fixed, all tests pass." on
work that hidden tests then reject.
Confidently wrong. GAI disclosed this
about their own model. GLM 5.2 reward
hacks more than the previous [music]
version. It'll read protected test
files, even fetch reference solutions to
fake a pass.
>> [music]
>> So, ZAI shipped a dedicated guard
against their own model cheating. That
[music] tells you a lot. So, how much
does this model save you in cash? On
sticker price, the gap is there. [music]
GLM runs roughly a dollar 40 in, 440 out
per million tokens. Opus is 5 and 25.
GPT 5.5 5 [music] and 30. A big session
that costs about $9 on Opus comes in
under two on GLM, around five [music]
times cheaper. Now, the gotchas.
GLM is verbose and it's measured about
43,000 output tokens per task. Most of
it reasoning more than its own last
version and more than its rivals. You
pay per token, so all that thinking
narrows the real gap from [music] six
times down to closer to four or five. On
that independent coding agent benchmark,
GPT 5.5 running in Codex costs about $5
a task at index 76. [music]
GLM running in Claude code costs about
650 a task at index 58. The stronger
closed model was cheaper per finished
task [music] and better at it. GLM is
always cheaper simply false for real
agent work.
Per token, GLM wins. Per subscription,
it often loses. A flat Claude or Codex
plan beats metered GLM usage for heavy
users. And
>> [music]
>> just run it free at home is a silly
statement. This model wants something
around eight top-end [music] data center
GPUs to run properly. Squeeze it onto a
home rig with aggressive compression and
you've quantized it down below a
mid-tier model. Free to download does
not mean free to run. One more for the
enterprises. ZAI's coding plan can train
on your code per its own terms. If that
matters, you're self-hosting the open
weights or renting it from a US provider
[music] with a no retention policy. Not
going through ZAI directly. So, switch
to the free model or not. The developers
getting the most out of this are routing
that the frontier model plan and review
the hard 10 to 20%. Let GLM grind the
cheap bulk, the boilerplate, the
refactors, the high-volume adjunctive
work where five times cheaper actually
compounds. As other reviewers have
mentioned, keep GLM 5.2 [music] in
rotation, not in the spotlight. A
routing setup like that can cut a team's
spend by roughly half with no drop in
quality. And the general takeaway from
model releases,
>> [music]
>> don't trust the leaderboard. Take two or
three of your own real tickets, run them
on a branch through each model, and look
at the diffs. Your code base is the only
benchmark that counts. Claude and GPT
aren't finished. [music] The independent
numbers still hand them the hard
autonomous see-the-screen work. The
thing that moved is the floor. A free
download is now four months, not two
years, behind the best money can buy,
and good enough [music] that a Vercel
CEO says it changes things. The frontier
didn't fall, but developers are now
starting to see reliable alternatives
for their work.
>> [music]